hello and welcome to Vienna Tom and I
are here getting focused on please get
very close to me Tom and I are here for
the EGU 2016 we're giving talks hey
we're not at all scared so we're off to
our first session which is dynamical
meteorology and that's actually all
we've got on today really yes I think
this afternoon we're both giving
frantically finishing up our
presentations because we're kind of
giving them to the world's experts in
our fields tomorrow oh hang on the
automatic escalators Oh
so Tom and I went to our first set of
talks on dynamical meteorology and it's
in the same room that we're talking
tomorrow and how would you describe the
temperature it was quite war was
uncomfortable we're going to be sweating
a lot tomorrow waiting to give the talks
and giving the talk also to my left I
have Laura it just snapped a picture of
me Laura is the head of giving you a
social media for the EGU so I'm a
pairing on a panel with her so actually
you're not on the pan you are organizing
my pairing on panels tomorrow and on
Thursday which should be fun
once this talks out of it I can relax
and enjoy that kind of thing but how you
feeling about your talk well I've been
like this actually yeah we're trying to
be etched I'll put that up on the screen
yeah we're both a wee bit nervous about
this only at the talks today meant fine
I thought it'd be good to go and see
some dips and yeah people didn't die
nothing caught on fire if the end of the
word you know the worst thing that
happens is you get a boring talk and
people ask me some questions and that's
it yeah you know what was really to fear
to be honest so in an interesting
development our supervisor isn't coming
we aren't able to pick up his poster and
fill in to him we haven't seen this
place before we don't know what's on it
he joked that it might just be a large
picture of one of our fellow scientists
we literally don't know so this is just
got more interesting
almost sexy
let's find out what this is somebody
else's yeah how many work yeah this is
for the real again yeah okay take two we
know this is the right one now my job
would be presenting its game show it is
as simple as you said it was it is Marc
Luber product and not really yeah and
they want to cut up one okay right sorry
yeah we would turn these in the water
hard as a as a tripod ingenuity
basically each academic poster up to
months of work for either one or a team
of academics and there are now I think I
think there's about 15 thousands
abstracts being presented
your person it's a really really
interesting experience was very unique
to academia it's very bizarre so now
we're meeting up with some people and
we're going to be going off to get some
dinner before Tom and I settle back to
our rooms to practice our talks
pretty good about tomorrow actually it's
now a talking poster and
get ready for I don't even know how to
say hi max file Hawks I stand firm and
earth and Starro tongan please tell
that's one way it turns out there's a
whole section of the menu about Tony
Blair drum was offered to day 10 I was a
teenager you know so dinner was fun that
was a bunch of Englishmen a Scotsman a
Belgian Dutchman I think a German going
to a Mexican restaurant in Vienna run by
a Czech gentleman he was excellent was
really nice dinner actually seems to be
like a specialty fish place even though
I was Mexican
tomah's being slightly freaked out by
the fan of the fish is looking at him
yeah it's given in new york and i oh but
i was really good and I reckon hotel I
definitely didn't forget my supervisors
poster I had to run back for it I'm
gonna run through my talk a few times
and get a good night's sleep because
tomorrow is kind of what the hell PhDs
been loading up to I guess which is
kinda scary thought I don't want to
think about too much but then again the
PhD is cumulative every day the PhDs led
on to the next day and the next day
because hopefully you're constantly
learning so tomorrow is just another day
of constantly learning it's just that I
have to give a public talk to
specialists in my field and sit on a
panel and present a poster that I don't
understand that well I'll cost we go
wrong ok so Tuesday morning this is the
big day we've got
put this bad boy up who start the first
thing in the morning then Tom and I were
drop off our presentations to give 10:30
and then once we drop off Rick and
practice a wee bit give the
presentations then I need to go and
start thinking what I'm going to sound
this panel but social media ending the
panel then after the panel actually
presented this poster by the fact we
don't really know we're talking about so
the big one
okay what's this it's the legendary
automatic escalators
it's called the groom
extreme about 10 that Pasco surface of
this index and shows that all the events
stand with influence of extreme event
intransitive persists in the province
where for 160 days as we begin to
understand more Oh [ __ ] go on seven
twelve pounds it affects both short-term
and seasonal weather patterns as shown
in open windows in 2001 and that's the
talks done that was kind of fun in a
weird way and we got a little bit
grilled after it's Tom more than me
they've playful talks one off the other
and we had a little bit of pushback not
hostility but you know people there was
one guy who was quite determined to say
stuff to us and then I had a chat with
people after it got through the whole
session a big variety of talks but went
well didn't it wait sorry that way yeah
yeah it was okay there were questions
and they were okay but it was the
professor he really kept drilling you
anyway he was really so much as a
standing up and telling you things yeah
yeah which was nice I like he's a ears
now he's now some we need to look up and
really needed to talk as well he did a
talk and he his papers and the papacy
reference looked interesting even if it
was slightly uncomfortable it means that
you learn something so science everyone
right let's see and then we got a panel
to go to having this fly out no no no
before that we've got the active
earthing active a cookie so much going
on
this amazing goods officers sim shell
and life this changes everything for us
this is a concept service for you by now
as a part of all of the team sets vow is
naturally fascinating to a boy a micro
paleobiologist about carbon cycle life
on Earth was amazing
so they've introduced the system where
you can scan your name badge and it
tells you much you're worth I know it's
telling us that he's got a talk right
we're off to our panel on books are not
the author Tom is off to my panel on
social media in academia and I just
missed the stairs ah look it's me la la
la la la la look it's get starts the end
of the social media panel tom was the
assistant cameraman and all the shots
you see of me are on Tom's thank you
very much that was fun we're all very
different people we had we had a blogger
a blogger they put this guy a Twitter ER
and a
and and Roth who was just his own
amazing person who I might be
collaborating with in the future if
you're watching this trial hopefully we
will be now we can have a look at some
posters
oh and presentable oh I forgot
for the long day I need a drink
it's actually really nice to talk to
people about this we do know a lot about
which is really interesting Chuck
doesn't it very interesting Java so Mr
Justice Leah
Vespas incident
oh we are done today that is one the
longest days of the PhD yet that was
getting in before nine leaving after
seven giving a talk being on a panel
presenting a post they're having a lot
really the interesting chats but has a
lot rest of the comments is a bit on
chill we've got to think about everyday
but this is the meat of it over and I
don't if you can tell but I am really
really tired and I'm gonna go to sleep
at like 9:00 very amazing look how much
a day is like the lighting in here is
super super dramatic we're waiting for
this session it we it might be a rosetta
session erm I've been astronaut session
I'm here at Tom I'm here with Mario you
follow my videos yes
you say that as if like you're hesitant
to admit it yeah you in most of the year
so commitments oh cool
and you were at Manchester day yeah
what's your stuff what do you do I'm
looking for microbes that inhabit the
lower part of places cool so completely
different from the oil kind of shows the
diversity of stuff that goes on yeah
really because all your events took
different tamiya basically yeah I'm
totally different in fact from this yeah
but you know this is has this everywhere
it's not an illustrative never one thing
spaces go
selfie the austere disappear so we want
me to tell you something you love
so the events still going on there's a
bunch of people over there but that
session that was that was a Matt Taylor
from Ito who is on the Rosetta mission
and that was absolutely fantastic -
really really interesting and I got a
selfie with him afterwards got to shake
his hand really really cool dude you
might remember him as the guy who got
some controversy from wearing a shirt
with scantily clad ladies on a press
conference and there was a whole [ __ ]
about that really really solid dude and
that was that was an accent talking I'll
see if I could find his stuff online and
put inscription because he's check him
out really good
we just saw posters in comic fans shame
on you
so last night was fun we get crashed a
hydrologist party and got dinner and now
we've got this is the last day the
conference already and we're off for us
anyway there's a date we're listening
tomorrow but we're going off to a
session on polar climate change and
perfect ability which is relevant what
we do and then I'm on a panel about
filmmaking we then allow this ocean to
drop the low freezing in order to keep
open water way we want open water
this should might seem strange
physically to allow that sub-freezing
temperature so that was a very useful
session we just found out about static
shot an escalator um but we are we found
out about a new statistical technique
which we're going to be trying to apply
is it this way that way that way which
we gonna be applying to our work so I've
now got someone to email and papers to
look up and that's a whole area of
investigation we didn't even know
existed up until about half an hour ago
so great stuff and we are done that's
the end of the conference proceedings
for me at least the session on
filmmaking was really interesting so it
was great to take questions from people
in the audience
and kind of give back I went to the
session that session exactly two years
ago because I was in the audience so I
found myself repeating a lot the advice
I was given and I drew and what I've
been doing on YouTube and then we also
had the session afterwards which is on
promoting your videos and stuff which
was really good I got the audience by
the way to say hello to you that wasn't
so hard was it
and now that's it we have that we had us
and talked to went to and seen posters
and about to leave and go back home so
thank you very much for coming with me I
hope this was enlightening to you this
has definitely been one of the best
comparably best conference I think I've
ever been to this was absolutely great
stuff thank you to Laura for asking me
to be on the panels and being such a
great social media manager for the EGU
and hopefully I'll be back here again
next year thanks for watching it's
taught me several analytical skills
taught me how to approach a problem come
up with an idea test the idea and then
move forward so I am not at all worried
about about a large part my PhD isn't
going into my pieces and in fact there's
a saying at least amongst quite a few
people here which but it does raise the
question that offer me which I I
personally think
which I put on display you like like an
online persona